[Music]
good evening welcome to tucker carlson
tonight so the Canadian Prime Minister
Justin Trudeau got caught wearing
blackface and a lot of people are
pretending to be very very surprised but
are you really surprised in fact you
probably could have guessed it actually
it's a little like finding out that
you're super sensitive brother-in-law
the one who tells you he's a feminist
the one who's always scolding you for
your sexism is in fact hitting on the
babysitter
of course he's hitting on the babysitter
the virtue is always a cover for the sin
that's the key to understanding the
modern left whatever they're accusing
you of doing they're doing themselves
but more enthusiastically and that's
definitely the story of Justin Trudeau
like your brother-in-law with the
ponytail Trudeau brags about being a
feminist use the wrong word in his
presence and he'll launch into a
self-righteous lecture Justin Trudeau
maybe the most sanctimonious head of
state on planet earth so of course he
was leading a secret life as a racist
that's why he's so sanctimonious so you
won't notice turns out there now at
least three separate instances of Justin
Trudeau wearing blackface and as he
conceded today there could absolutely be
more you left us with the impression
there was only one other incident and
since then Global News has released the
video which seems to show that there was
at least a third incident so exactly how
many times have you darkened your skin
with makeup in an act that you have
yourself described as racist I shared
the moments that I recollected but I
recognize that it is something
absolutely unacceptable to do and yeah I
appreciate calling it makeup but it was
blackface unacceptable but you did at
least three times maybe more how many
times you you weren't in blackface
probably right around zero
try not to be judging here or anything
but even adjusting for youthful
indiscretion three times on camera
that's a lot it's an awful lot actually
what's going on with Justin Trudeau well
it turns out and he explained this today
that Justin Trudeau suffers from an
especially virulent case of something
called
vilage I have always acknowledged that I
come from a place of privilege but I now
need to acknowledge that that comes with
a massive blind spot uh-huh
got that white privilege is the problem
here
that's Trudeau's explanation if you're
not listening carefully it might sound
like Justin Trudeau just took
responsibility for what he did but no
just the opposite
he transferred it when Trudeau blames
privilege
he's moving responsibility for what he
did from himself to the rest of us in
other words I did something awful
because society itself is rotten
therefore and this is the key therefore
I need to keep telling you how to live
your life it's not a confession
it's a justification and the only people
dumb enough to buy it are the news media
of course the dumbest people in the
world over at CNN for example Don Lemon
was deeply impressed Wow a leader of the
pausing that it seems odd doesn't it I
mean because we have one who doesn't but
he says you know he says he didn't think
it was racist at the time now he knows
better what do you think of that but I
do have to say this before we go think
about it however you want to think about
it it when someone apologizes Wow we've
never we don't we don't often see that
here especially a world leader who's
saying I should have known better and
I'm sorry
you can feel about it however you want
but that to me that does mean a lot I
gotta go thank you
means a lot to Don Lemon it really does
what a difference a year makes if you
can remember back all the way back to an
megyn kelly of NBC found herself under
attack in pretty much the same way the
difference was that megyn kelly never
wore blackface
she wouldn't do that she's not Justin
Trudeau she just made the mistake of not
seeming quite offended enough in a TV
segment by certain Halloween costumes
for that crime Don Lemon told us she
must be destroyed it's gonna be honest
Megan is 47 years old she's our age
there has never been a time in that in
her 47 years that black face has been
acceptable I wonder how much diversity
she has understaffed I don't know I'm
not there but I would imagine there is
not a lot because people would have
informed her this is what people of the
larger culture don't understand about
racism and about privilege
uh-huh keep it in mind and this is
universally true was true of Jimmy
Swaggart is true of Justin Trudeau and
probably true of Donnell Mont the more
sanctimonious you are the more you're
hiding you want to know who's up to no
good look at the people who are tugging
their chin in you I would never do that
and yet suddenly Donilon went from that
I wonder how much diversity she has on
her staff - oh I'm so glad that Justin
said sorry did Donnell Mon have a change
of heart as you know a forgiving man or
could it be that because Justin Trudeau
is a powerful leader on the left he gets
a past no matter what he does I think
you know the answer because of course
you've seen it before earlier this year
the governor of Virginia Ralph Northam
was caught wearing blackface actually it
was a Klan hood he still won't tell us
which it was but whatever it was he was
wearing blackface or a Klan hood nor
them a liberal Democrat decided he
didn't need to resign over it the left
pretended to care for a few minutes we
were so upset and then they forgot the
whole thing ever happened
Northern himself said that the incident
showed I'm quoting deep wounds in
Virginia what he did [ __ ] on deep wounds
in the whole Commonwealth of Virginia in
other words Northern himself wasn't
guilty of anything blackface were a Klan
hood it was the people of Virginia who
were responsible they had the collective
guilt and that guilt could only be
expiated by giving Ralph Northam more
power because that's what it's always
about always it's about power when you
make a mistake it means you're a sinner
and you must be damned you probably
don't have enough diversity in your
offices down the line but when they
screw up it's society's fault
meaning it's your fault so then
you coming and going it's pretty nice
actually it's a good trick being woke
means never having to say you're sorry